- So Halloween is coming up.
I know you got kiddos, so what do y'all,
do you dress?
'Cause I know that we had
the cute little photos
of your children, but I
also found this one of you
and I just have a quick
question here, Andrew.
(everyone laughs)
Like what?
I don't know that I've ever known a kid
that dresses-
- Oh my God.
- as the Pope.
- The Pope, yeah.
- You're a very serious kid.
- It's a very Catholic idea.
- Very serious.
- My brother and his family are here,
so he was witness to this.
What's up?
- Rannells family.
- Hi.
- Um, so yeah, my grandma Josephine
had this idea that I
was gonna be the Pope.
So she put together that costume.
She got me, and I was the Pope.
And my little sister Natalie was an angel.
But it was like, but it's
still like hands down,
I'm 45, that's my best Halloween costume.
- Oh my God, I love you.
- It's the pope.
- I just love that I-
- I peeked at fourth grade.
- Can you imagine trick or treat?
I've just never seen a
kid dressed as the Pope.
- As the Pope.
It was very, I was very popular.
- [Kelly] It's usually
like Tony Stark, Iron Man.
(Josh laughing)
- [Andrew] It was very popular.
People took a lot of pictures with me.
- That's incredible.
- It was like, yeah, I felt-
- [Kelly] You were a hit.
- I was a hit.
- [Kelly] Okay, well I have
to pull this one up too.
- [Josh] Yes, please.
- This was last year.
- [Josh] Yeah.
- And this was incredible.
- Yes.
- This was, this is incredible.
(audience cheers)
- [Josh] I mean...
- [Kelly] Flotsam and Jetsam.
- What's really complicated,
what's really complicated
about this picture
is I was also trying to be the Pope.
(audience and Kelly laughs)
- [Andrew] It is tricky.
- There're layers.
- Something went very wrong.
- [Andrew] Someone led you astray.
- No, I lost a bet with my daughters.
I lost a bet.
They said if you lose this bet,
you have to be Ursula for Halloween.
And so I ended up being
Ursula for Halloween.
- Please tell me you walked
around trick-or-treating
with them singing "Poor
Unfortunate Souls."
- Oh a hundred percent.
- Okay.
You would've let me down.
(audience cheers)
- Oh yeah.
- Do you like to dress up
or do any Halloween-
- I love to dress up.
- All right.
- I love a theme.
I don't even wanna go to a
party unless it's themed.
Like,
- Yeah.
- Like why, we're just
- All right.
- Gonna hang out and be ourselves?
That's boring.
- Just in general,
you don't like to go to any parties
unless they're themed?
Or just Halloween?
- I'm a, let's be real...
- I'm sorry, I can't attend your wedding,
unless everybody's
dressed up as a character.
(audience laughs)
- I did wait, I did throw a
themed party one time though.
And Enrique Iglesias showed up and-
- No.
- Because we had
the same manager at the time.
I don't hang out with famous people,
I'm not cool.
And I, but he showed up
and he wasn't in costume.
And at that point I'd had a lot to drink.
(Josh laughing)
And so I was very bold
and walked up and was like, get out.
You don't have a costume on.
(Josh laughing)
I was like, you have wear
a costume to be here.
And I was like, I'm just kidding,
but kind of get out.
I'm sorry.
- Also get a costume.
- [Josh] Yeah.